first topic today and
look it's a wednesday
there's not a huge story that's
screaming out
we must cover it other than this one and
we must cover what's gone
on with antonio brown the past couple of
days even though it hasn't caught fire
the way that it
should the way that it could or the way
that it will if the nfl does what it has
the power
to do in the aftermath of the news that
broke
late monday afternoon that antonio brown
was involved in an incident october 15
at the gated community in which he lives
in hollywood florida
where he allegedly broke a security
camera allegedly threw a bicycle at a
security guard shack
and police according to the report that
was generated had probable cause
to charge him with misdemeanor criminal
mischief the president of the homeowners
association decided not to she said
among other things
that she feared retaliation against her
staff yeah
okay fine and it happened before he
signed with the buccaneers and the
bucket has quickly issued a statement
chris
making it clear no harm no foul this
happened before we signed him
he's been a guy who complied with
everything we wanted ever since we
signed so they're not going to do
anything about it
the question is what is the league going
to do about it that's what we're
discussing now because it came out
yesterday that the league is looking
into it as
obviously they would i never understand
why the league's first reaction
to something like this is we're aware of
it and we have no comment well how do
you have no comment
you have no comment at least say we're
looking into it which is what they do
the next day
first day we have no comment then the
next day they say we're looking into it
and they leaked yesterday to one of
their on the payroll in-house reporters
at nfl media
they didn't know about it before antonio
brown was reinstated
that chris is the thing
that if the league wants to do it they
can
suspend him immediately they can
discipline him swiftly because there is
a
clear obligation under the personal
conduct policy to let the league know
when you've been involved in an incident
even maybe grounds for disciplinary
action
he apparently didn't but but even mike
and before you read the
the language here even if there was no
charges pressed or anything like that
it's still on the duty of the player to
tell the league that there was an
an infraction at this point i mean i
know it looks like it's look
you can read it you can read it texas
yeah can you read it texas
i can wow it's right in front of you
right the answer to your question is
right in front of you i just that's so
broad i i mean i i don't yes it is broad
failure to report an incident will be
grounds for disciplinary action that's
not broad here's what's broad
the obligation to report is you know
what's broad the word broader
broader than simply reporting an arrest
it requires reporting to the league
any incident that comes to the clubs or
players attention which
if the allegations were true would
constitute a violation of the policy so
if it's true
that the guy engaged in misdemeanor
criminal mischief if it's true he broke
a security camera at a gated community
in hollywood if it's true that he throw
a bicycle and a security guard shack as
part of some
altercation and argument if all that's
true and the police were there
which they were and at the end of the
day they didn't charge him
that's not enough to escape the
obligation
to report it to the league especially
when you consider his history
and my guess is at some point someone
from the league said to antonio brown
yeah as they were resolving all these
other issues and there's still one
significant unresolved issue with
antonio brown
you know a civil lawsuit alleging sexual
assault and rape
somebody i assume i hope i would think
said antonio brown you better stay out
of trouble
and if there's anything that happens
it's even remotely
resembling trouble you have to let us
know about it
so we can look into it and decide
whether or not we need to intervene and
take action
and the fact that nearly a month more
than a month
32 days went by from incident to when it
became public
if the league didn't know about it and
again it all comes down to what the
league wants to do they've set these
policies up so they can do what they
want when they want how they want
there's enough there though if they want
to throw the book at him they can
yeah i mean you're right there's enough
there they they can
i mean first off i i mean
the league nfl pa whatever i mean it
doesn't sound like anybody knew about it
second off like secondly second off
secondly
i wouldn't think you know antonio brown
listen i i don't know of that rule i
have no idea
i was a player rep at one point i don't
know if players would register in their
brain
to call and for lack of a better way to
say it
tattletail on themselves hey guys you
know
self-report themselves i know i didn't
get arrested but i got a lot of trouble
here i
i really you know towed the line of
getting arrested but didn't i just
wanted to report that and let you know
you know that's not gonna happen and
especially with a guy like antonio brown
who probably nobody has warned him of
anything but
yes he knows he has to be on his best
behavior he's probably scared as hell
when the
when it all got done that day or
whatever and going oh man i hope nobody
finds this
finds out i hope the nfl doesn't find
out i hope it doesn't break in the media
anything like that
so i would think his natural human
reaction
would be not to tell anybody not the
opposite even though
you know he's in a very weird situation
in this this whole thing here because of
the pending
you know situation that you talked about
and that's why
it's important to have competent people
around you
who provide you that's true advice right
agents
lawyers read the policies who can look
at the language that you and i just
shared with the world or at least anyone
in the world who cares to be watching
the show
and a reasonable person comes to the
conclusion
anytime you get yourself on the fringes
of an incident at least let someone
around you know so they can decide
should this be reported to the league
because it's always better
if you let it be known on your own
than if they find out and they're always
going to find out this case is proof
positive
they're always going to find out it's
always going to come out
anytime there's a police report
generated yeah there's going to be
a mechanism a pathway for that report
to make its way into the mainstream
attention span whether it's an
industrious reporter
who's looking through the police reports
somebody get catches wind of it there's
a tipster
or there's somebody in the police
department that has a friend with one of
the
newspapers they have a good relationship
they get a fruit basket every christmas
whatever the case may be
they send along police reports that
maybe a reporter would be interested in
right their public records right
right so i don't know that the average
player
has any reason to know about this other
than the fact that the policies out
there and i would like to think that
when we are conscious of the ray rice
situation and other
high profile personal conduct policy
investigations
and punishments like ezekiel elliott
from a few years ago
i you know most guys never get in
trouble so it doesn't apply to them yeah
they're never going to get in trouble
that's the thing we're talking about a
policy that applies to a very small
percentage of players the vast majority
of nfl players
will not get in trouble will not even
get close to getting in trouble
right but the ones who have gotten in
trouble and the ones who have been
suspended those are the ones for whom it
becomes even more imperative chris that
they know
and they understand what the rules are
and again
i doubt that the league didn't say to
antonio brown at some point i don't know
this this isn't one of those somebody
told me and you can
you know don't don't say that someone
from the league told you you could just
couch it as your own idea no i
this one this is one where i am truly
spitballing but it seems logical to me
that someone
in the league office would have the
foresight to say to antonio brown
if anything else happens you need to let
us know
immediately so we can deal with it and
it doesn't
emerge in the miami herald or some other
publication
and we get caught flat-footed with
questions yeah from people who want to
know
what we think about something that we
don't even know about well you didn't
tell us
that's where it it's like i know and i
don't know if that message is conveyed i
really don't
i mean i i i just i would wonder who
comes out to say that
and then i just go back again to you
know antonio brown there
october 15th not on a football team you
know dying to get back in the league
i just can't imagine your thought would
be to call the nfl
and again telling myself so why
they could know and then maybe when the
bucks start to
you know get some of the business
dealings with antonio brown the league
lets them know hey there was another
incident
and i don't know we don't know if this
doesn't look good
to where now the bucks go all right that
so we we won't touch him whatever so
he's he's put himself in a really tough
spot
to where you know he's well yeah because
he got involved in an instance
he shouldn't have gotten involved gotten
involved in so many incidents that
even if he did know that rule he's
probably would be scared to tell people
that
and then doesn't want to tell people
that because he wants to get on a
football team other thing i want to ask
you mike
hang on i got a question for you i got a
question because we live in a crazy
upside down time where
the right thing to do has gotten lost oh
totally in so many different ways and
this dovetails with what what i want to
talk about later in the hour
but obviously the right thing to do is
don't get involved in any incidents
where the police show up that's the
threshold
general right thing to do but when you
find yourself in a situation like this
the right thing to do clearly even
though chris you're saying the
temptation is there to keep your mouth
shut the temptation is there
to let nature take its course and get
your contract signed and get back in the
nfl and this is something you've been
working for and you've been persecuted
by the nfl and why are they giving me a
hard time right
yeah yeah you can excuse it 50 different
ways to sunday
but but what's the right thing to do you
tell me what's the right thing to do
once you're involved in an incident yeah
when there's a clear policy that
imposes on you an obligation to report
it what's the right thing to do yeah the
right
would be to report it certainly right
yeah and let you know let them know
like you're right so they can kind of
fight the battles they need to fight
and do what's best not only for them but
with you
included involved with them in that
business transaction so
i i understand that it's just a yeah
this is a guy that's not exactly famous
for the right thing to do
so you know he will not go down in
history as
antonio brown did the right thing most
of the time no that's not going to
happen
the other aspect i want to ask you about
this mike because
we talked about it a lot in the off
season and and
in you know antonio brown conversations
but okay so the nfl starts to look
things up here and blah blah blah
and they don't like what they see you
know and they're on the fence about
suspending them again
or doing or taking action and we know we
got you know the civil suit pending down
the road
you know do they take into account the
things you talked about
so much we both talked about about how
he served his time and then some
you know as far as a suspension is
concerned with all the games he missed
last year and this year
does that get part of the conversation
you think for the nfl
well i hope so and see this is where it
becomes
difficult for me because we start
spinning different plates of
righteousness like antonio brown
should not be getting himself involved
in these incidents and he does have an
obligation under the rules to report
himself but at the same time
the nfl screwed with him last year
using this vague threat of putting him
on the commissioner exempt list if he
signed with a team
as a way to keep him out of the league
last year
they kept him away from a team he wasn't
employed
because they were uncomfortable from a
pr standpoint
with the idea of antonio brown being in
the nfl
well you never know what we're going to
do about the commissioner exemplist you
never know
well are you going to put him on it or
not well we're not telling you whether
or not we're put that's up to you so you
may be paying this guy to not play for
you
hey that's not our issue that's yours
and what they did to him last year was
wrong because he served a 14-game unpaid
suspension
as they took their good old time
investigating the allegation of sexual
assault
and rape and that's the strangest thing
about his reinstatement
the thing that kept him out of the
league last year chris
is the thing that they still haven't
resolved i know that's why i just
wondered that that's not resolved yet
and yeah i mean you're going to suspend
him for something that
yeah i just i wonder what their thought
or how they're going to approach this
that's all i'm saying it is extremely
strange
uh certainly here's how they'll approach
it yeah however they want whenever they
want whatever they want and
and look the nfl's in-house justice
system does not give me a ton of
confidence
it is a pr tool masquerading as
a device through which they do the right
thing right
let's get gets back to doing the right
thing no they want to create the
impression they've done the right thing
and sometimes that means punishing a guy
sometimes it means
not punishing a guy sometimes it means
this vague threat of the commissioner
exempt list
so you can engineer a situation where
the guy isn't employed but you haven't
had to suspend him so i don't like
anything about the nfl's in-house
justice system
i thought it was misguided from the
get-go it was a reaction to the ray rice
situation
but it gives them the power to do
whatever they want to do
and then they can work backward to
justify it however they want to justify
it under the terms of their various
policies
a lot of companies do that they have a
stack of policies
yay high that they can sift through and
find
one piece of paper that justifies
letting them do whatever it is they want
to do
regardless of whether it is the right
thing to do here's bruce arians
coach of the tampa bay buccaneers from
yesterday
talking about this latest antonio brown
chapter
you have brought women into football in
a way that other coaches don't
and some women's groups were were
wondering why you would bring antonio
brown
in have you had conversations with
anybody on that front what would you say
to them about that yeah i've answered
i've answered that one a few times rich
and it's
you know trust me i mean
i think what you said the record of how
i've
pioneered for them just trust me in the
fact that
i'm gonna give this guy this chance and
it's just a chance
um and let all that handle itself in the
courts
and all i can ask them to do is trust me
on it
yeah see that didn't address the latest
incident that's the pending incident the
allegation of sexual assault and rape
for which
there were never criminal charges you
can always pursue one of two avenues if
you're the victim of
of that type of conduct you can go to
police you can go to the civil justice
system
and brittany taylor went to the civil
justice system and yes it is pending in
the court see
that's the that's the way that aryans
and the buccaneers can kick the can
through 2020 because he knows damn well
the courts aren't going to issue a
verdict in this case
until 2021 at the earliest
it's due to go to trial in a few weeks
there's no way in hell it's going to
trial in a few weeks
so we'll let the courts handle it will
they handle it i don't know hopefully
long after antonio brown has retired
from football that that's that's the
game there
so uh yeah you're doing a certain amount
of a deal with the devil
when you sign antonio brown in the
history given that given the pending
allegation because if it's true that he
committed sexual assault and rape of
brittany taylor i don't think he ever
should play in the nfl again
i don't know i mean he should be in jail
if it really is true but
there's levels of proof sometimes you
can't really
uh produce the objective evidence that
resolves that he said she said that is
at the core of so many of these
situations
but uh there's enough smoke there that
uh uh and look the league decided not to
reach a conclusion for whatever reason
chris so it's a complicated situation
a lot of it is murky a lot of is unclear
the one thing that is clear
there was an incident october 15 that
based upon the nfl's in-house media
conglomerate
the nfl didn't know about it wasn't
reported to the nfl
if the nfl is so motivated to go after
antonio brown again
it can now look based on its policies it
should if it wants to have true
consistency in the application of the
rules that apply to all players
the question is will they you never know
no it's always whatever they feel like
doing on any given day it's never
consistent that's what we know i mean
you've explained that already it wasn't
consistent with
the last suspension with antonio brown
so that's where i
that's why i was wondering like you know
maybe will they take that into account
here with this situation
i don't know the one thing i could sit
there with right now just
what i really think about is i i already
go we're two weeks in or three weeks in
i just wonder if the bucks are already
going man
did we what did we do here i just wonder
i mean you know
you got the okay we're gonna change our
game plan for the saints and play away
we haven't played all year because we're
gonna
you know i don't know appease antonio
brown
and tom brady and everybody that way get
blown out you know
go back to the way we want to play kick
butt you know everybody's happy oh wait
this antonio brown thing's going on now
we got to talk about that again
and those issues and you'd have to
wonder
what else do we not know i mean that's
the other thing that i would
be very worried about with antonio brown
are we going to hear something that
happened on september 15th too
here in a few weeks i mean that's where
i would really be on the edge of my seat
if i was
a big time player there in the uh
buccaneers organization
just you know when is that other shoe
going to drop is there
going to be another story we're going to
have to deal with is there going to be
another bit of information that's going
to come out from the civil suit
that looks really bad and then we're
just gonna look bad in general that we
got the guy on the team
i mean they got to be thinking some of
that right now um
and you know i'm still i'm still shocked
bruce arians did it i really am i'm
shocked but i'm not shocked i'm shocked
because
he's so steadfast against it and it
doesn't seem like it's his type of guy
i'm not shocked because
tom brady's there and of course we
thought this might happen
if his behavior in the lawsuit
that was sparked by the incident where
antonio brown allegedly threw furniture
off of a balcony
at a miami luxury condo and he was sued
for damage done to the apartment if his
behavior
in that litigation is any indication of
what he'll do in this litigation
oh it's going to go off the rails what
ultimately happened in the other case he
lost a default judgment meaning
he was so uncooperative with the process
the judge eventually said
that's it it's over you lose we don't
need to go to trial
we don't need to have a jury come in and
decide
whether or not you did or you didn't
damage this property
you lose because you have disrespected
the
process now we just have to figure out
how much you owe
so uh and and that was uh you know
failure to comply
to produce information and ultimately
when it's time for him to sit down and
answer questions
he and we've seen videos of different
celebrities who get themselves in a
deposition setting and they are just
total buttholes without the butt
right with a different word that's kind
of how he was
and he had to go back and do his
deposition again so when it's time for
him to be questioned aggressively by the
lawyer who represents brittany taylor
that's when the whole thing could go off
the rails and be
not credible that you could watch the
video
of the deposition you could read the
transcript and come to the conclusion
this guy's not innocent this guy did
something
because of the way he's handling himself
in this situation so that's looming
now it's probably not going to happen
before the end of the season but it's
going to happen before the case goes to
a trial
and that's the thing that the buccaneers
if they're still employing him chris or
the nfl
if he hasn't retired from the league
that's the thing they need to get their
hands on
because they need to come to some
conclusions based upon how he conducts
himself in that setting
yeah definitely uh you know this is
where i just don't
the nfl the process everything with some
of these cases it just i
i just feel like it's it's got to change
a little bit it's got to be a little bit
more
you know consistent like you said and i
just
who knows where this goes i really have
no idea um
and let me just say one last thing and
then we can take a break
very well right but it very well may be
there's a mental health issue with
antonio brown that's undiagnosed and
untreated that was why drew rosenhaus
stopped representing him earlier this
year
that he he wanted antonio brown to get
help and antonio brown refused to get
help
and there are families that struggle
with this all the time where you have
adults who can make their own decisions
who refuse to get help when they need
help that's why they engage in
self-destructive behavior
and there are a lot of people in prisons
throughout this country who at the
at the fundamental core of their problem
is a mental health condition so
you know we can only hope that at some
point the light bulb flickers enough
that antonio brown gets help if he needs
it but until then
he's expected to comply with the rules
of a normal society
and one of them will be sitting for this
deposition and giving truthful testimony
and one of them is at least in the eyes
of the nfl
reporting an incident if you're involved
in one so we'll see what the nfl does
with that moving forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports